I still think about the night your
mother and I had to leave you generation
over an uncaring void of darkness look
Hollywood no matter how realistic the
de-aging technology gets it will always
feel uncanny because our brains know
it's fake and we know what they look
like now and just wish you'd stop is
anyone really trying to tell me that
Batman Begins would've been better if
young Bruce Wayne was a CGI d.edge
Christian Bale all on Newsies instead of
a totally different child actor that
didn't maybe look like Bale but did the
job acting wise we both knew that if
he'd go that small there's no coming
back
narration that was proven false by the
previous movie and this movie a few
seconds he's even going to counter this
very statement so why not just have him
say we both thought it should have been
me that my regulator was damming and
that would mean these movies would have
had Michelle Pfeiffer's one of the leads
and God forbid a woman be the successful
inventor of scores of useful Marvel tech
I mention Marvel being like buddy
Ackerman's office and swimming with
sharks avoid women they obviously do you
know what that does do I three months
shoo you've got to think big think big
think banner big start ah bad wigs I
think it's possible to bring her back
and I started to think it's possible to
make pigs fly but I've still got several
legal and moral hurdles to clear before
any country will give me permission to
cut off a pig's nose when surgically
attached a propeller in its place this
reveal is cute until you realize that he
was in jail for stealing and now he's
play-acting stealing with his kid and
then it gets a little less cute fuck it
Santa looks like Scott saw Dave made
amazed
so therefore Scott made amazed I want to
take it to show and tell why so that
there will be a five-minute sidetrack
later in the movie where he has to go
into the school to get it back that's
awfully prescient for a ten-year-old to
think about a screenwriters wishes I'm
in the middle of trying to steal
something with my daughter he even says
the word steal how many conversations
did he have with her where he was all
stealing for real is wrong and that's
why daddy went to jail but stealing for
pretend is fun so let's do that together
in celebration of the fact that daddy
isn't in jail for stealing anymore
everyone's gonna call this the he's a
great dad scene but if she'd flown off
this cardboard slide contraption and
gotten a concussion we'd all be
rightfully blasting his ass as a
terrible and reckless father you're
really great with kids
thanks I'm also youth pastor pop quiz
assholes thanks I'm also a youth pastor
is a what I say whenever I get
complimented on my hygiene be a spicy
Albanian religious Cola drink see
saying I had tattooed on my penis and D
the only sworn testimony I have ever
given in a court of law it was their
text that they violated the courts
- how does creating tech like ant-man
suit before the Accords were a thing
violate the Accords about the Accords
were just a set of rules stating the
superheroes had to twiddle their thumbs
until the government needed them to
fight crime under their supervision if
it was discovered that Scott stole the
tech how does that make Hank and hope
libel how'd you do it Scott he means the
magic trick look this is the pronoun
game dressing up as something else look
I'll be honest these ant-man movie is
deserve praise for portraying a modern
family that includes divorce and
stepdads without making it feel weird
in fact these movies go out of their way
to show how uplifting and positive
co-parenting can be for divorced parents
once in remove this guy has three more
days of house arrest to kill before
freedom and he goes drum practice
plastic bowling even six-year-olds would
turn up the noses at goddamn magic
lessons online private karaoke John
Green novels origami and Hopkin goddamn
is the dude ever gonna turn on the TV or
watch some porn nothing passes time
better than TV a porn mommy this is
apparently a real-life memory of some
sort because blah blah blah blah quantum
realm blah blah married to the mob is
stuck in the quantum realm and that's
pretty much how this movie explains it
do you think it was a dream or is it
possible that you really saw my mom down
there no because he's supposed to know
that I have a feeling that if you were
driving a car this small for a trip this
long getting smash would be an
inevitability also while the car is
small it's not undetectable people would
see this tiny car making intelligent
driving decisions and definitely pick it
up and see what the fuck is going on
it was a matter of national security the
cap needed helps cap hope interrupts
this bull reason Scott is giving to join
caps signed in civil war basically
because it's a joke about how he
casually refers to Captain America as
cap and so you won't realize what a
ridiculous decision it was the whole
first ant-man was about him doing things
to see his daughter because he cared
about his daughter more than anyone in
the world to join the fight with a bunch
of rogue Avengers and potentially be put
in prison for life is something not only
Scott wouldn't do but cap would never
ask him to do under those circumstances
what barely tolerate your in beginning
and the small inning technology at all
but simply can't abide the idea that you
built it into it can car model also is
there a reason you drove here small only
to park large was it just a demonstrate
the tech I think it was just a
demonstrate attack okay these giant ants
roaming around like worker bees or
mailroom employees here they can golf
and die I am so uncomfortable right now
also these CG ants or fake doesn't
Marvel Disney have enough money now to
actually enlarge real ants and train
them at this point I first sure erect
the ecosystem for art why doesn't this
multi-billion dollar company no
seriously are you paying these ants a
living wage because if not this feels
way icky er than a shared understanding
between species it's a tunnel to the
quantum realm leap one you don't need a
tunnel just wear the suit and go two
levels deep boom Bob's your uncle you're
in the quantum realm try the veal this
huge Duracell a product placement only
accentuates what a waste of science this
is you could solve nearly all the
world's problems with this shrinking and
enlarging technology but it will never
be used in that way we think when you
were down there you may have been
tangled with her and so therefore you
had a dream memory of a very real thing
that happened I don't understand it
either but thankfully it happened
because now the band's back together and
we can start ant manning the wasp your
mom put a message in my head come on
that's insane guy who has literally
shrunk down and let an army of ants into
battle says that's insane like he's some
kind of authority on crazy scene
descriptions once we get the component
and power up the tunnel we'll get the
message and have you home by lunch we
have to hurry the entanglement won't
last you owe us never ever ever have six
seconds of consecutive dialogue than
this confusing if you try to keep your
shrinkable lab a secret why do you place
it anywhere in the middle of the city in
fact why don't you just always keep the
building Trump then shrink to go inside
and do your work and only a large when
you need to be enlarged I mean does no
one see this and what about the
electrical and plumbing lines into this
bitch not to mention all the four dozen
other issues this movie ignores about
shrinking a building also I hate you
also also how's the solution to infinity
warned not these fools just making
Thanos a tiny gummy bear and eating his
ass so he drowns in stomach acid no he
could simply tell Scott that there are
no Altoids in that box but why do that
when you have this big surprise up your
sleeve later when they get all kidnapped
by ghosts walton goggins plays a bad guy
in a movie cliche quantum energy is the
future okay this is like when the human
guy in Avatar demanded more unobtainium
it's literally just like that we look
the other way because the MC was great
but still you know what's cooler than a
million dollars 1 billion dollars hold
up what is that on the plate in front of
her bars of dub so cut open and filled
with coupe giant deviled eggs the three
seashells from demolition man hope is
now kicking all of Birch's henchmen
asses which makes me wonder why she or
PIM didn't just shrink down break into
wherever it was and steal the component
in the first place why do they even
stick their necks out when they were
already one of them further supposes it
sokovia accords crimes hell tim is such
a genius why didn't he just build it
himself a mother built a goddamn quantum
tunnel alright alright I am out it's
kind of tech makes pretty much the
entire MCU worthless this is raw magic
but we're powerful than even Harry
Potter ever saw also I just don't
understand why she would need to do that
which she's perfectly capable of
speedily flying to the door to prevent
him from doing that herself
it's like those x-men Quicksilver scenes
only when I don't regard for the viewers
equilibrium or designer not to throw up
fight scene editing brought to you by
the MCU there is one place I can think
of no no no no no we all know what that
means beetle we're going to the place
that Hank doesn't want to go to anyway
despite his strong objections it's one
of those hilarious things that crops up
in four out of every five movies these
assholes who work with Luis and even
though we some self argue about oatmeal
for 20 seconds and somehow people were
still wondering why this movie didn't
fully connect with viewers oh do you
guys just put the word Quantum in front
of everything no lie I literally wrote
this exact thing as a synth then he says
this and now I have to delete that
earlier sin and make this a Scott would
be excellent at cinema cent cent wait
you might be able to improvise that
tracker if you modify the diffraction
units on one of your regulators that
sounds just vague enough to work the
postal service is very reliable you know
they do tracking numbers now this movie
is just one conversation like this after
another and it's not cute I looked
everywhere here I put it back after
Cassie and I were put
shaunti yep Scott's going to go to
Cassie school and get the ant-man suit
out of the trophies she brought to
show-and-tell he will do it with
virtually no conflict this teacher will
ask for a Hall Pass and will give up
when Scott runs away and Cassie's class
will be out to recess when he looks
through Cassie's back child-sized Paul
Rudd sounds a lot more fun than the
scene ends up being that's a shame what
are we gonna do convenient lost and
found bucket in a janitor's closet and
not the principal's office is convenient
let's go and even though the bell rang
Scott and hope run out of the elementary
school without anyone noticing in fact
is this a field trip day or something
sorry I had to come up with the name of
my aunt I'm thinking Ulysses esker am
another casualty of egg Tim's
dunt dunt in addition to being super
helpful about how they could locate the
lab Morpheus is also the surrogate
father for this ghost chick the odds are
astronomical holy Elias
Starr they were colleagues his shield
quantum research this exposition is
cloaking but at least no one's quipping
about oatmeal or the post office when I
woke up my parents were dead but I
wasn't because quantum reasons and
trained me to be a stealth operative he
find out later that she only gets away
from shield while shield falls apart so
she must have been so stealth that we
didn't even see her in the big Avengers
missions where she could have been a
huge asset she's in there somewhere damn
it I just know she is in exchange for my
soul they were going to kill me God she
has been talking for 57 minutes then she
told me about Lang and the message from
Janet inside his head bill is giving
very important information here as the
story builds a little momentum and the
movie interrupts it for a joke bring it
down I lock it in I was gonna say Hank
is a dick to these ants but then I
realized Hank is just a dick going some
atomic isn't something you can prepare
for
kind of melts your mind if Hanks wife
isn't a completely changed woman after
being in the quantum realm for thirty
years and this whole thing's along oh is
that too strong there's no such thing as
truth serum that's just nonsense from TV
newsmen and the ex-con security team
will argue about whether they should
call this truth serum for some time and
the reason why is Minh will just let it
go is because why exactly is he trying
to guard some reputation for the bad guy
underworld where truth serum is
considered hack I tolerate a lot of the
things you do out there but I won't be a
part of anything like that wait what
exactly has she been doing besides
following and Hank and hope for the last
two years she's been committing other
major crimes other than stalking her she
was an operative of shield for a hot
minute but that wasn't her decision I
like a good story as much as the next
person but what the hell does this have
to do we're Scott Lang here I'm getting
there I'm getting there
you put a dam in him you got to let the
whole song play it's really an excuse
for the movie in Louise to tell his
drunk history style stories again and
while those are funny and everything I
bet if he took out all the side tracks
in this film the movie would be 50
minutes long
oh the woods the woods ghosts decides to
blow her cover to demand more specific
answers as if birch wasn't going to ask
Louise to elaborate on what he meant by
that that freak is Pam's tech I'm never
gonna see it how many bad guys are in
this movie systems in the green priming
the coils stomach batteries to power
turbines to speed
shutting down maybe our vectors are yeah
I agree
gotta be the vectors like sixty percent
of the time it's the vectors every time
I'm sorry I don't know how much time I
have I need to fix the algorithm this is
where the movie goes from harmless
inconsequential marvel entry to
downright silly Michelle Pfeiffer's
quantum brain possessing Paul Rudd as an
entanglement so unwelcome they might as
well call this movie I could never be
your woman part two jelly
[Music]
this plot convenience is so weird that
now hope could officially say she's had
sex with her mom you have two hours
after that the probability fields will
shift and it'll be another century
before they align like this again a
detail that comes out of nowhere I guess
they were lucky they got the machine up
and running when they did it's totally
made up so that there will be added
pressure even though they just sat
around letting Michelle Pfeiffer waste
away in the quantum realm for 30 years
with no problem defense they know where
you are and despite that they will
somehow totally fail to get to Scotts
house before read us even though Goggins
told the FBI guy about it sometime at
night then it's now sometime during the
day see the night in the background
that's night but continuity aside even
if it only happened five actual minutes
ago the FBI would be at Scott's place
way before his flying and could get
there from the Muir Woods I'd also like
to point out that the Muir Woods is a
tourist attraction and placing a giant
lab in the middle of it is going to be
spotted by somebody even if the FBI
wasn't tipped off by Sonny Burks it's
also kind of a dick move no other
members of law enforcement see this
Benedict Arnold take the lab and put it
in a Strunk vision we will see you in an
hour
the FBI leaves these two internationally
wanted criminals in this basic-ass room
unsupervised two people known for
inventions that make people small and
can potentially escape the situation
even if you search them don't Hank and
hope deserve a stronger holding cell
with guards yep they're getting out of
this because she has a hair pin in her
mouth people in charge of Hank and hope
are dumber than the ones who were
supposed to watch Ted Bundy in Colorado
that looks load-bearing how would the
shrinking device know to shrink the
entire wall wouldn't it just shrink the
one brick to which it attaches
[Music]
that'll work it's stupid but it'll work
look just because the buildings been
placed in a nearly abandoned part of
town doesn't mean people don't notice
like that in comps who patrol this area
are gonna be like damn a whole new
building just sprung up out of nowhere I
better investigate he's no Ned but
Louise is definitely great and worthy of
a syndrome oh man I'm following Sam I
thought we could use some help that's
why I didn't tell you until now right
before we go into the lab I just wanted
to save him she's facing death of
something far more terrible what I still
don't understand how the ants gained
super intelligence just because they got
big holy this movie just got a lot more
Timecop than I think it intended to so
she's a super genius a badass at
hand-to-hand combat a professional stunt
driver she's basically all the things
she's Trinity in the Matrix movies
downloading new skills on a fly is
needed
I won't that lab boys whatever it takes
do you have all your evil black SUVs
equipped good that's half the battle any
reason why she can't just do this and
stay small until she finds a safe place
can't she just shrink and hide the van
pull out the Hot Wheels rally case
change cars thereby evading virgin his
crew awesome the quantum realm has whale
songs Mike so you yes because they took
out four SUVs the clear solution is
motorcycles also are you holding back
some of your men for a second wait do
you want the lamp or do you want an
extended chase look I don't hate fun I
like fun and this is fun it's just the
ramifications of this casual application
of biggie smiling technology across the
MCU as a whole concerned me greatly I'm
beginning to think when screenwriters
write big Hollywood movie there's a
space already filled in we're crazy
happens an average citizens don't see it
on page 84 somewhere you have to include
it her Cary Grant busts out of his
coffin to eat you he hasn't driven in
two years and it was a problem but he's
able to just nice skateboard this bitch
like he's been nice skateboarding trucks
his whole life huh legit did not think
you could crash down here Darren
Aronofsky's wreck-it Ralph
good job ho now hopefully I don't wreck
the car into innocent people
who I'm very results-oriented so it was
a great decision on your part great job
how did you even have time to buy a
ticket
impossible action is justified through a
throwaway joke I guess I'm no extra
dimension expert but I feel like the
quantum void should have the same helmet
removal as bad rules as outer space he
means about marrying Catherine
zeta-jones while his first wife was
trapped in the quantum realm I'm not the
same woman I was 30 years ago Henry yes
you are just because you say it doesn't
make it so aside from some ET powers
that we'll see later the same person
adaptation is part of it but some of it
is evolution how are you not dead like I
get that because you're so small
metabolism probably isn't a factor so
you don't need to eat anything but we
saw the tardigrades going in for an
attack earlier and then there's the
whole mind-melting fight in addition to
other issues but really I just wanted to
write a sin that said dirty grades in it
[Music]
let's go if you've never seen a movie
before allow me to spoil for you the
fact that the FBI man will at least one
more time in this movie be too late or
get fooled again just FYI I'm cynical
enough about the citizens of San
Francisco in this movie that they
probably didn't even see this let's go
see our time truly this has been a
fantastic voyage you are in dirty water
with no light trying to find a guy who
is aunt sighs oh my keys this I guess
this is where we say adios mio that's
super racist also ex con ex machina ex
Konica Comic Con
she's stealing her G she started the
extraction she's gonna tell mama parts
I'm sure they explained how ghost was
gonna zap Janet's quantum energy and put
it into her to fix her condition and I'm
sure the idea is complex but it ends up
feeling way too simplistic this is Paul
Simon's favorite scene in the entire MCU
and that was how mantis was born Scott
Lang's house in this market could easily
sell for a few million dollars earlier
he and Luis were revealed to be lying to
their employees about how broke the
company is no one will be seated during
the everything worked out so well for
everyone we are literally using the song
come on get happy under this montage
portion of the movie when I see Hank
take a mansion out of a jewelry box and
plant his home on a beach with his
beautiful wife I'm reminded how asshole
ish this looks considering all the
people he could help with this
technology and what great but don't
flush those toilets y'all
just given the potential for all kinds
of death and dangerous scenarios when a
human being is the size of an amp with
the moth dust and getting stepped on and
drowning in a single drop of rain why
not just watch this on a TV inside
drive-in theaters aren't even a good way
to watch a movie as an experience yes
they are fun and can be nostalgic and
create memories but from a pure movie
watching standpoint it's pretty far down
the list of desirable ways to watch a
film
just below edited for television and
just above on a handheld black-and-white
portable TV and don't get sucked into a
time vortex we won't be able to save you
how did you avoid the time vortex when
you yourself did not know what one was
until you spent 30 years in the quantum
pool I have a lot of questions about how
you survive down there also this is
foreshadowing for endgame that is trying
very hard to just appear to be casual
technobabble
remember when he went into the quantum
realm in just the suit in the first
movie and then in this movie they had to
build a whole inner spaceship to use to
go into the quantum realm to rescue
Janet who had also entered their quantum
realm in a suit but now they're just
sending Scott back into the quantum
realm and only a sip confuses my ass
guys so there were four of them here on
top of the parking garage he goes into
the quantum realm
Thanos snaps and somehow random 50%
death across the universe results in all
three up here getting dusted that seems
more driven by story than randomness I'm
sorry and yes I know it's perfectly
within the realm of coincidence but I'm
not buying it here because they need
Scott to be trapped in the quantum realm
in order for avengers endgame to resolve
so they had to dust everyone up here
that could have brought him back a
drumming ant aren't you glad you waited
the full 10 minutes of credits to see
that are you not entertained
because that's how you get ad spread out
what is this a center for ants
you think that's air you're breathing
now they shouldn't sit
[Music]